Hello 2 2 In the opinion of foreign people,
why is the mukbang doing that? I think you will be happy in any way. I do the
station alone, I don't
eat it, I eat it together
[Music]
Because it's a mukbang, the number of room broadcasts because of the date we ate because I was afraid of road casting, so
I saw it as a mukbang.  I think
the purpose of mukbang is literally to eat. So eat deliciously, and
hey, you have narrow jaws.
[Music]
Why do the viewers start to have a desire to see it? But,
[music]
eats that with sound.
Uh
[Music]
I am a mcu who has been broadcasting for 19
years. It started less than 8 years ago, so I started watching muk shows a lot now.
Thank you
I tend to do it about 4 times a day. At first, I saw other people doing
mukbang, so I thought I'd try it more than once
.  If you do, many people say that it tastes better and it tastes like you eat it.
Now, I
actually have an older sister in the neighborhood, my sister in the neighborhood, and the domestic Myuna
. It seems that everyone sees a lot of cancer.
I don't work well and sometimes I get tens of millions of dollars a day,
so the
competition needs to be developed a little more qualitatively
.
As for food and my mukbang, I only eat a set amount for 30 to
40 minutes, so
I don't eat a lot or binge eat.
I'm an artist.
In my opinion, this is the
first
Uh, traditionally, from the old days, we ate together and valued such a community culture.
For example, as we
moved to the modern era, there were many single-person households.
Because there are so many of them,
I
probably live alone, but while watching a mukbang,
I wonder if I can see something that feels like eating together.
[Music]